[Applause]
thany
girl
thank
you to learn who rules over
you simply find out who you are not
allowed to
criticize mark this day on your
calendars remember it because it is a
rare day virtually
non-existent where I or my colleagues
can speak on a college
campus it's most
disturbing that at the University and
it's not just uh one particular or a
series of universities it's across the
country that is supposed to be the
center of great
debate supposed to be the diversity of
opinion where only one opinion is
sanctioned where only one opinion is
welcomed and so first I want to thank
Professor
Sidman for inviting me to speak here it
was Brave the students who stood up for
me to speak I know it's not easy I get
to leave the campus you have to stay
which is why student groups are loathed
to invite myself or noni darsh or Waffa
Sultan or Ayan or Robert Spencer or iben
War because they are intimidated they
are
harassed and this is an anantha to
[Applause]
America speakers who speak for
Freedom
americanism Israel are considered the
political dissidents and honestly that
term is not even used that lator term is
not even used the fact is faculty
members ad Administration officials they
cave and they cower to demands by
Islamic
supremacists and Sharia enforcers now
what do I mean by what do I mean by
Sharia enforcer that's fair that's fair
someone who doesn't know someone who
doesn't know will laugh because in this
country it is laughable in this country
it is
absurd that we have to sue to get ads up
that we would that we would consider
I agree I think it's
funny that we would sue to get ads up
because you cannot criticize Islam under
the Sharia you cannot criticize Islam
you cannot offend Islam and it's
punitive in Muslim countries as you know
those that are charged with blasphemy in
Muslim countries are put to death under
the Sharia here your character is
assassinated here you are smeared
defamed and libeled for questioning
Creed apar tide gender aparti Islamic
Jew hatred these issues are not allowed
to be
discussed and that is why I discuss
[Applause]
them
if speech that offends a group is
prohibitive if speech that offends a
group is outlawed that group has
absolute
power and a free to society Society is
destroyed a group that cannot be
opposed will be tyranus will be tyranny
and that's what we're seeing in many
countries AC across the world the idea
that we would seek to impose it here or
adhere to it by voluntary
means is
devastating and debilitating and
shocking for Freedom lovers across the
world you must be free to offend in a
free
Society it's
critical inoffensive speech doesn't have
to be protected
it's offensive speech that has to be
protected and it's not the Fifth
Amendment and it's not the Eighth
Amendment it's the first amendment and
it's the First Amendment freedom of
speech for a reason because a free
Society is contingent upon freedom of
speech a free Society depends upon
freedom of speech without it peaceful
men must resort to violence now let me
give you a little background
how do I come to this prior to 9/11 I
was apolitical I assumed my freedom I
was the quintessential New York career
girl I was the associate publisher of
the New York Observer I love my fashion
I love my music I love my art I love my
life I assumed my freedom I never for
one second thought that it could ever be
taken away from me come 9911 I felt
guilty I didn't know who had attacked
this country and when I found out I felt
guilty because I didn't understand who
attacked this country so understand
where I'm coming
from I
was a freedom uh lover you know I just
I I just I just I just assumed
[Music]
it I just assumed it
and the more I tried to understand the
threat the more uh those of us who are
covering it were smeared defamed and
lied for discussing
Jihad now let let's let's talk about
islamophobia for a second it is
islamophobic to oppose Jihad Terror
because that's all I do I I you know
this claim that it's all Muslims no
you're making that claim not
me I clearly don't believe all Muslims
support Jihad but I don't have to pat on
the back every Muslim that doesn't want
to kill me I expect that but there is a
problem there is a problem and we have
to be able to talk about the problem and
the problem is we can't talk about the
problem because this is what
happens you have Islamic supremacists
calling Brookland College to cancel the
talk why why it's a free Society why why
would this be controversal IAL but it
is the ads that I run again let's talk
about why I run those ads how I run
those ads where did that even come from
I will tell you after seeing a number of
vicious anti-israel ads running I
responded now there was no resistance to
Those anti-israel ads there was no cont
controversy about those anti-israel ads
thousands of them ran across cities in
America but as soon as I discussed the
Jihad against Israel I have to sue to
get the ads up and mind you here I don't
know if you saw today's paper because we
had a ma a major win yesterday this is
Page it's in all the New York papers but
this is page 10 this is page 10 of of
the New York
Post the headline the
headline the headline should
be the headline should be she had to sue
for this that the that's the headline
the headline is your taxpayer dollars
are used to not only fight these ads
going up the ref suppression of Free
Speech but my court case my legal courts
are reimbursed by you I have sued five
times I have won five times and you have
paid five
[Applause]
times it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable you should be concerned
why am I running an ad quoting
Kamas I'm running an ad quoting uh Hamas
because the Council of American Islamic
relations a designated a designated
terrorist group by the United States
government an United co-conspirator by
the United Arab Emirates run an ad ran
an ad rebranding you have to be
quiet you have to you have to let speak
and then we'll do a Q&A and then you can
speak and that's how it's going to
that's how it's got to be
done they ran an ad campaign rebranding
the word Jihad it's deceptive there's a
problem Christians are being slaughtered
in Nigeria Catholics are being
slaughtered in the Philippines across
Africa the Islamic state is rising
across the Middle East whole swads of
Iraq and Syria have been taken over by
the Islamic State they consider them M
eles devout now I am not saying that
everyone follows this particular um
authentic or Pure or literal Islam what
I am saying is that they do and it is a
problem and we have to talk about it so
the idea of making the Jihad a warm and
fuzzy term is absurd and so I created a
campaign quoting high-profile Muslims
whether it was the Prime Minister of
Turkey or the Fort Hood Jihadi or the
times Square bomber or Hamas who said
killing Jews is worship to
Allah and the ad was refused do you know
why the ad was
refused the ad was refused because the
chief security the security chief of the
MTA thought that it might incite Muslims
to kill
Jews a that sounds islamophobic to me
but that is why if you read the court
opinion if you read the court opinion
it's why the ad was denied the ad was
denied because they were afraid that
Muslims would be radicalized by the bus
ad a ridiculous premise a rid absurd on
its face because if if you're going to
kill a Jew because of the Islamic
anti-semitic texts in the Quran a busad
is not going to make you do it a
fanaticism will but a busad won't so we
had to sue we sued and we won and Those
ads are going to go up I'm going to buy
50 to 100 of those
[Applause]
ads why would I buy 50 to 100 ads
because most people think that the war
against uh the Jews in Israel the Jihad
against the Jews is about stolen land
which is
ridiculous it is a religious
war and most people don't understand the
root cause which is why I I run these
ads because there's only one narrative
there's only one narrative on the
college campuses there's only one
narrative in the media and what is at
stake is everything everything you love
you hate you hold and condemned about in
this country it's the only country like
it and you won't like what comes after
America you won't and it does grieve me
that it is so difficult to have this
conversation excuse me how to shut this
off freedom of speech
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah America's intellectual leadership
has
collapsed I give you
this
[Applause]
room what better way to declare what
better way to declare that the
intellectual leadership has collapsed
but in the belly of the
Beast speakers that uh speak against
Israel these these they're welcomed Jew
haters are welcomed but my speaking here
on behalf of all of you I mean my work
there's much of my work that's never
discussed
Muslim girls who don't want to wear the
hijab Muslim girls like AXA parz Muslim
girls like RI gabar that don't want to
wear the hijab where did they go who do
they speak to I stand for you you want
to wear the hijab you want to wear the N
you wear it I speak for the girls that
don't want to I speak for the girls that
want to lead a western life I you don't
speak for those girls where were you
when rifa Barry was threatened by her
family where were you when oxa parz nor
Al Maliki Amina and Sarah s why didn't
you take to the streets when sha alaw
was murdered and they blamed they blamed
Robert Spencer and me and it turned out
to be our husband in an honor killing
how come you didn't wear a million
hijabs for sha alati it was only when
you thought that it was a hater or a
terrorist she was killed by her husband
how come you didn't take to the streets
and stand up for sh sha ala or Aja
Hassan or nor Al Maliki where are you
women where are you hiding when they
hiding when they want to get to safe
houses you laugh because you're free and
you're making your choices that should
be good for your sisters too there are
girls that want to get to safe houses
that's what we do we get them to safe
houses but we don't talk about that work
because it's inconvenient it doesn't
adhere to your Sharia
Koda that's right
nothing strengthens Authority so much as
silence there is no debate here it's
just incredible you want me on the wall
you want me fighting for your freedom
whether you whether you agree with me or
not yeah uh yeah you'll remember these
days you remember these days you you you
need me fighting for your freedom
whether you agree with me or not whether
you agree with me or not this is the
premise of of this country I don't know
what I do
this this is the pre this is the premise
of this country this was a country the
first moral government in the history of
mankind based on individual rights on
individual rights the first country
based on individual rights and property
rights and everything Noble and
Brilliant and and and just that this
country achieved was a logical Fidel to
that principle can you stop talking in
the back
please what about
na we need a revolution of the
mind we need a philosophical
Revolution uh to counter the this
intellectual PCH this intellectual catar
this is completely this this
this the fact is is the university life
is becoming increasingly more fascist
more dangerous if you if if you don't
subscribe to the narrative
Jewish Jewish students across the
country are harassed and bullied should
they express yeah do you think it's
funny you know this is what a bun rally
would sound like okay this kind of uh
intimidation and and and and and
bullying are bullying you
no the fact is you should be very very
concerned because these the these
Islamic supremacist revolutions that
have now turned into the morphing
Islamic State which by the way continues
to
grow I it will not it what was that
what' she
say continues the Islamic State
continues to grow and she says thank God
you know what that says it all you know
that says it all I can't there's no way
that I can ever possibly relate to this
kind of savagery you know I watch these
videos every day 10 years ago when
Daniel Pearl was murdered this country
royed in disgust and revulsion we were
galvanized we captured khed shik
Muhammad now it's every day did any of
you watch yesterday's video out of the
Islamic State a 30 minute video the
first 16 minutes explaining by is isamic
clerics citing Islamic texts and
teachings citing Quran for what they're
about to do 16 minutes of Islamic text
and teachings and then Ethiopian
Christians who refuse to convert were
beheaded and shot to death this is every
day and you say
insha I don't get it I I got to tell you
I don't get it yeah
I I will tell you that if it's what's
the difference Islamic State and alqaeda
what's the difference Hamas hasah I mean
the fact is there's a problem in Islam
and you're coming after me I ain't your
problem seriously you want you want
you're obviously in this country because
you believe in Freedom otherwise you'd
be living in a country under the Sharia
you obviously are here because you
believe in Freedom for everyone no
special rights for special
classes right no special rights for
special classes am I right or wrong
absolutely okay so so that's why you're
here so I don't know how you could
possibly not be concerned with what's
happening in previously secular or more
secular Muslim
countries it's it's very scary it's very
scary and you should be on the Forefront
the moderates should be on the Forefront
fighting it you should be standing
shoulder toosh shoulder with me in
defense of freedom of speech and
individual rights we stand by
you well you're very
sweet
um
okay the idea of offensive speech which
is why you know we're here today and the
inability to uh speak freely in the
marketplace of ideas and we can't
because the last time I can tell you
that I spoke at a college campus was
years ago Temple and it was it was
Madness and it is madness many times
when we still what's up it's it's
Madness many times when um uh my
colleagues on the rare occasion get to
speak look at aan her Al she was given
awarded brandise now really whatever you
feel about aan she's a reliable witness
I mean she was born and raised in the
culture she escaped and whether you like
her or you don't like her she deserves
respect her trial and her tribulation
deserve respect and yet she was uh she
was disinvited from brandise are you
comfortable with that do you think that
that's right right it's outrageous it's
outrageous you are the
future you know I live my life I live my
life and I was
free this is your fight freedom is your
fight this is your fight I wish to
assist you you do not appear to want my
help but the fact is this is this is the
most critical Battle of your
lives how many secular
Muslims are bullied intimidated harassed
and slaughtered as apostates because
they're not practicing or considered
devout they need
you the the Free World The Free World
needs
you and I do find it discouraging that
when we're talking about beheadings and
FGM and Creed apartheid and in all of
these acts of jihad Terror they separate
the Muslims from the Christians and let
the Muslims go that you
laugh there's there's a savagery in that
too you know yes that
nonetheless I only ask you can laugh
with your
friends you I don't mind honestly I
don't mind I know I understand peer
pressure but you I speak
I like I said you you laugh with your
friends but I speak to each one of you
in individually I speak to each one of
you as a as a fellow human
being to try and and and think for
yourself to try and be a rational being
to see what's going on around you to be
cautious about what's happening in this
country one only has to look to
Europe to see where you could go they
have these hate speech laws where for
quoting for quoting Churchill a British
politician is put in jail is arrested is
that what you want to come here even if
it's even if it is your belief system is
that what you
want because if you do then it's just
it's not compatible it is not compatible
with the
Constitution and it does not belong
here and I feel that if you're in this
country you love freedom it's why you're
here you love the choice you love the
choice you want to wear a burer you wear
you don't want toar you don't you want
to wear a colorful
uh the choice Freedom that's what I'm
fighting for and I am fighting against
totalitarianism whether it was a hundred
years ago I'd be fighting stalinism I'd
be fighting the National Socialist
Workers Party which is Nazism but today
it's political
Islam and the body count is too high and
the denial in concert is too high and it
cannot be done it cannot be addressed
without the the the moderates in the
room
I'm I have absolutely yeah I applaud
Zionism as
well I know it's funny it's funny that
the Jewish people should want a tiny
itty bitty state when there are 57
countries in the 57 countries in the
organization of Islamic conference 57
countries in the organization of Islamic
conf conference but the Jews who were
half were exterminated can have a tiny
Jewish State this again speaks to it
speaks to the perversion of the
narrative before 1967 there was no such
word ever used as Palestinian it was
greater Syria go back and look but
before 48 before 1948 before the
establishment of Israel in the British
Mandate of Palestine Palestine a word
that the Romans renamed Israel in order
to humiliate the Jews when they lost
against the Romans in before 48 there
were Palestinian Muslims and there were
Palestinian Jews living in the British
mandate Palestinian Muslims were
conducting po Rams against those Jews
this is a very old war this is a very
old war and if you don't know the
history of it don't open your mouth
learn first first learn
[Applause]
everything the Palestinians are the Jews
the Palestinians are the Jews the
Palestinians were given Palestine in the
League of Nations 1920 Sano resolution
again yours your yours yours is the
illegal argument not mine and you should
want the Jews to have a little piece of
land what's the big deal let the Jews
live and I will tell you what the big
deal is the big deal
is the big deal is According to Islamic
texts and teachings Israel is offensive
to The Devout I have here I'm not going
to read it because we ain't got till
midnight but many of the Islamic text
and teachings calling for the
annihilation of the Jews it is a
religious imperative it is up to you to
work to sponge these teachings from your
belief system that's
critical you must you must you must in
order to live as as human beings as
civilized men this is what is required
of you why can't you be the new
generation wouldn't that be something
wouldn't that be something for you to be
to to to to to fight off the elders a
and the ugliness and the hate and the
Creed apartheid and the gender apart T
wouldn't that be something really Earth
shattering for you people to do you want
to change the world that's where you
start change yourself first on that on
that note well listen I could change
myself that's listen That's My
Prerogative you can change yourself I
fight for the prerogatives I fight for
the prerogative that's what I'm fighting
for the premise of all my ideas ladies
and gentlemen is individual rights
that's it I'm not anti-religion
I don't care I don't care what you
worship just let everybody else worship
too just let everybody else live in
peace
too and if you choose to stifle speech
you'll be next you'll be next who's
going to decide what's good and what's
forbidden the government who's going to
decide what's good and what's forbidden
what can and cannot be said you are who
no I'm not me I believe everybody should
speak who's going to decide the Islamic
State bah
Haram think about it you know what's
going on in Pakistan and Afghanistan the
imposition of these Free Speech
laws and Christians Asia B they're being
put to death because of a perceived
insult to Islam is that right I ask you
do you consider that to be right you
have to fight against it yes it is your
job as a member of the human race it's
your job to fight against oppression
suppression and
Slaughter on that note I think I I'd
like to take questions I'd like to take
of the
audience questions just so that you know
are limited to 30
seconds no
speeches you want to make a speech get a
room book yourself and
talk
are
youum apparently there's a lot of
turmoil overseas and in America a lot of
Injustice so I was just wondering um
Waka Flaka flame that's our presid
[Applause]
201 Waka
yeah okay next uh campaign announcement
that was a very good
question hi I just wanted to confirm a
quote from you um so it's from 2008 it
is a great it is great to be a blonde
with low expectations is very easy to
surprise people do you recall saying
this no oh this is Pamela
[Applause]
Anderson
thank
you people here thank you and my
question
is how do you how do you educate people
who are ignorant who do not realize
that
Islam in its purest form in the Quran in
many places interes does
preach who do not adhere to Islam how do
you address that inurance well I want to
say a couple things there are certain
people that no matter what will never be
moved you know when Stalin when Stalin
died and they opened up the Googs and
they released the political prisoners
and we're told that ston was dead many
of the political prisoners started C
crime not from happiness they actually
cried CU Stalin was dead those people
you're never going to change but there
are millions of Americans that are just
misinformed there's been this huge
disinformation campaign for years uh
Jihad Terror Sharia has been scrubbed it
has been whitewashed it's it's peace and
all this nonsense and so this is what we
seek to do these ads that I do it seeks
it seeks to Leap Frog over the media
because the media is by and large Sharia
compliant and they um speak directly to
the people when I did the ads on Islamic
Jew hatred and I showed the picture of
Adolf Hitler and the leader of the
Muslim World m al husseini most people
don't know that the leader of the Muslim
World ra raised Muslim armies for Hitler
don't know that he was responsible for
the death of 400,000 Jewish women and
children they don't know that he lived
in the lap of luxury on Hitler's dime in
Berlin
that's why I ran that ad and the site
that it was linked to had hundreds of
thousands of hits so that's why we do
what we do we do it to educate and as
George Bush said you're either with us
or you're against us you cannot sit on
the F you cannot sit on the fence you
cannot sit on the fence on in this
battle there are no casual there are no
casual observers everybody every s
single citizen of the world is is in
this war yeah
yeah
sh you know I appreciate anyone who
comes and talks about freedoms and
rights you know I'm a of this country
I'm very proud to be I'm very proud of
my rights and my freedoms um and I you
know will stand with anybody who stands
with me for them yes now it's a little
difficult for me to take you seriously
because my first introduction to you and
like I'm here now you're telling me
about freedoms and rights my first
introduction to you was when you were
protesting opposing my community's right
to build a mosque in park 51 I used to
pray in that mosque and I came out after
it had been approved by New York City
the local Council and you were out there
and you were saying that we should not
build this mosque because 70% of
Americans don't agree with it isn't that
how is that not the PO that's a very
fair question thank you for thank you
for answering it actually I did not say
that they shouldn't build a mosque
because 70% of Americans 70% of
Americans opposed it I did not say the
government should shut down I did say
they had every right to build that
mosque but this is what I
said that building was destroyed in the
911 attacks the landing gear crashed
through that roof body parts were found
in that building and I thought it was
enormously insensitive and offensive
they would consider building a 15-story
mega mosque under the name kadoba in
that building I have never opposed there
are hundreds of building m MKS in the
city hundreds of mosques thousands of
mosques in this country you've never
seen me oppose them that particular
mosque was very symbolic and moreover we
have never seen in the history of Islam
a mosque dedicated to reconciliation and
healing never but we have seen countless
mosques built on the SES of jihad
conquests so I understand and by the way
I sympathize that you are a worshipper
there and but they've been worshiping
there since November 2009 okay I never
said anything I knew about it in
november9 you didn't see me say anything
the idea of building Mecca on the Hudson
I ask you sir
objectively if they built stop if they
built a 15-story mega mosque in that
building would that not have
been Mecca on the Hudson to the Islamic
State a build a building a MOS like that
look it's the Dome of the Rock is the
Dome of of the rock is right on top of
the first and second temple the Haj of
Sophia the most Exquisite Church in the
world they just turned into a mosque
again this is deeply offensive we're not
killing people we're not burning mosques
down but it's deeply offensive we we
appeal to Imam rou we appeal to him
that's all that that was yes I was
protesting it peacefully never violently
never calling for violence but asking
them to to
reconsider that idea now he said he's
building a a museum of Islam there did
you see me call for protest no a
three-story Museum but that was just you
you there was no Shinto
shrine at at Pearl Harbor they never
built a sh and the Japanese never asked
and even when the church was building a
Convent across from aitz and people were
up in arms the pope withdrew not because
there was a La not because he had to
because it was the right thing to
do
sure
thatt per example of that it was a Roman
Temple later to church and then later
converted to a mosque bought purchased
and Christians were always allowed to
worship there and it was done in cons
but you and I both know Christians are
not allowed to Worship in a mosque you
cannot you cannot worship in a Masque
unless you're being invited to Islam
unless you're being invited to okay
listen I unless you're being invited to
Islam and there's a deliberate and
there's a there's a deliberate yeah yeah
look I'm not going to debate CHR and I
[Applause]
went okay so now okay so okay wait a
wait wait a
minute
[Music]
can everybody calm down please
okay number one I am Roman Catholic you
do not speak in the name of me you don't
not you do
[Applause]
not Islamic because there's nothing
Islamic about them but Islamic State
kills Muslims and Christians the Zionist
State kills muslins and
Christians
land that was the entire land so first
of all that second of all thank you so
much to the
administration uh for giving us such a
relevant flyer we've been waiting in the
rain for two hours two hours and you
talked about the rights and everyone
should be treated equal no matter the
class well guess what people got treated
different today outside of the building
okay
[Applause]
no no my dear no my dear young woman I
do not speak for you but I fight for
your right to
speak I fight for the right of
every I
[Applause]
do I and from what I understand many
students were in here it's 6:30 way
before way before everyone I do not
speak for you but I speak for your right
to speak that's the first thing the
second thing is uh you may
say you may say the Islamic state is not
Islamic but they do and that's the
problem I'm thrilled that you don't
think they're Islamic honestly I don't
care it's irrelevant what you think what
they think is because they're killing
people as far as the Jews in Israel the
only country in the Middle East that's
safe for Christians is Israel now shame
on you shame on you for not knowing that
shame on you for that knowing that
yeah that's right that's right the only
country that's safe for Christians next
questioner please
[Applause]
thank um there has been a uh a trending
social media topic involving one of the
most most famous Muslims in media sorry
my phone locked okay uh this issue
caused heartbreak to millions of people
all over the world including myself and
my own family and I was just curious to
ask you how do you feel about Zay Malik
leaving One
[Applause]
Direction
questions are on the phone are not
leg you want
to listen the people that are not the
people that are not the people that are
not getting prompted should go first the
people the people with a genuine
question that are not being prompted by
their Puppet Masters should go first got
tell I don't
stop so um there's been a controversy
over a certain party returning to their
land and it affects millions of people
and I thought I asked for your input in
your honest opinion how do you feel
about LeBron
[Music]
[Applause]
Jah you're doing your school proud I
want you to know
[Applause]
that want a great
[Music]
School no no no no there is there is a
system no
[Applause]
no
[Music]
enough your white privilege isn't going
to work here what she
say you know something baby you are one
big
cliche okay no white
[Music]
privie hi we can hear you we can hear
you I
like please let the woman speak all
right so he can't hear
[Applause]
[Music]
you right okay if I don't talk another
person but everyone we can't hear you we
can't shut up maybe if you stop talking
[Applause]
shut how old are you it's okay when you
guys do it though
right
[Applause]
fingol oh you want know how much I pay
in security you want to know the kind of
death threats I get don't go there
believe
me
you can't hear
[Applause]
her okay so we can't hear you we can't
hear
you we all bet you got work in the
morning like this is silly if you don't
if you don't want to do this to you want
you don't want to do
it every time
I God this is kindergarten talk okay um
I'd just like to start off by saying
that uh first of all um the first
amendment protects you from the
government um making laws against your
speech but it doesn't protect you from
universities declaring that you're a
bigot okay and all right I just say that
is the most incoherent thing that I have
ever heard my freedom of speech is
across America second only to your
speech though
[Applause]
that's room to be quiet now I want to
say family thank you so much I want you
all I want you
all I'm not let me I'm not going to let
you sh me up survived genocide of 1979
Black September genocide committed in
aeran 8,000 people I live and I am half
Muslim and I have to tell you this and
my husband is Jewish and guess what yes
my
father and I have to tell you something
you want me read the Quan for you I will
and I have to tell you thank you so much
and I have to tell you I want you all
laugh that I survive
8,000 I have to tell you yes I lost the
faith because my father
is go why because if you so brave I want
your hands on the platter not
others a that's a that's a that's a
that's a that's a threat that's a threat
that's aat that's aat that's a threat
that's
aat I just want to say thank you so
much I'm not going to stop until I ask
my question thank you so much for doing
what you doing
my question to
you my question to
youed of
[Applause]
[Music]
spech
[Applause]
head on a plate who says that no off she
wasn't white
[Applause]
would you should
your despicable I I am ashamed of you I
am ashamed of you I feel FR I don't know
what to do shame on you my question to
you are you going to cut her head off
besides
[Applause]
[Music]
besides I one
question
guys guys come on thank you I am sorry
that's you came here I sorry that you
came here and I'm sorry that you were
disrespected this way it
is and speaks to the bigger problem and
it speaks to why I'm here you allowed us
to continue we are finished as a
civilization
finished I question you promise can you
promise not to stop your fight
[Applause]
against never never never again never
again
again good night ladies and gentlemen
don't don't hurt anybody on the way
[Applause]
out
[Music]
that's
[Applause]
picture
[Music]
100 on onve
[Applause]
[Music]
fre
fretin fre
fretin
[Music]
[Applause]
pal
[Music]
[Applause]
pal
Cal down C
[Applause]
[Music]
down
American you act like an American
[Music]
[Applause]
citizen free free pal free free pal fre
free pal fre free paltin the river to
the Sea The River To The
Sea